-Welcome back, Marty.
It's so good to see you.
-Good to see you, Seth.
You look fantastic.
I see that you've gotten rid
of all your Confederate flags.
Good for you.
-[ Laughing, stammering ]
It was time.
We decided it was time.
-Well, I'm very excited
to be here, you know.
As you know, there's no --
I think
of all the hosts that pretend
to care about their guests,
you're the one
who pretends the best.
-Oh, well, thank you.
You know, I think I really
put that skill to the test
every time you're here. So --
-Th-Thanks. Thank you.
-[ Laughs ]
-No, listen, no, I love --
You know, you and I,
I think we click. Don't you?
-Yes. Yes.
-Whether it's "SNL"
or "Late Night"
or the back of Jeffrey Epstein's
plane, you know.
-Yeah.
-Who was that lady friend
of yours?
How do you pronounce her name,
"Jislane"? "Galane"?
-It's Ghislaine,
but not a friend.
We're just --
-Ghislaine! You two were --
You two were on a roll.
You were playing that --
I remember she was knitting,
and you were holding the wool,
and you were laughing.
And I couldn't hear what it was.
-[ Laughs ]
-But I could tell you were
just -- Something was happening.
-[ Laughs ]
-Anyway.
-And, you know,
I know you're busy.
Thank you for making
the time tonight.
-Oh, please. No, no, I realized
that I had not been on your show
for over a year,
which is fascinating that --
how time flies
when you're ghost-writing
for Tucker Carlson.
-Yeah.
-It zooms by.
-[ Chuckles ]
-But I love your show, Seth.
And I wish
I could do it more, really.
But...pride.
-Yeah. No, I --
I could see
how that would get in the way.
-Hey, there was something
you said to me earlier
before we started.
So, you think they should
keep the name Redskins.
Why is that?
-[ Laughing ]
No, I did not say that.
I didn't.
-Well, then
someone said it to me.
-[ Laughs ]
-Who was it?
Oh! It's my --
the people who do my patio.
-How have you been
spending your time
with the extra time
that all of us have?
-[ Chuckling ] Well, you know,
the UPS guy and I are engaged,
if that's what you --
-Oh, congratulations.
-No, I'm on a very similar
schedule each day.
I get up around 8:00.
I have breakfast. I exercise.
And then it's around 12:15
at night, get ready for bed,
and then it's time for Corden.
-[ Laughs ]
-I love traditions.
-Yeah, it's true.
-You can have fun with the --
You know, and I, again,
follow the scientists.
In fact, I'm keeping
12 feet away from people
so I don't get coronavirus
next year.
See, I'm thinking ahead.
-Oh, that's smart.
You did appear
in one of the Zoom "SNL,"
the three of those
that happened this spring.
You got to perform with Heidi
Gardner, who is just fantastic.
-She is like a genius.
Don't you think she's fantastic?
-She is. There's real "SCTV" DNA
to the way she performs.
Don't you think that's accurate?
-I do agree with that, yeah.
It's -- She's so committed.
And when we did it, it was a
Zoom about, you know, two idiots
who had been to Italy
during the pandemic.
And she was making me laugh
every take,
because she was
getting her face all...
like this.
-[ Laughs ]
It was just fantastic.
And, you know, Beck and Kenan
and Aidy and Melissa,
they were all just so good.
-It's crazy to me that you were
only on "SNL" for one year,
because you certainly
made a mark in your time there.
Looking back at it,
do you wish it had been
a longer tenure at the show?
-I do. I wish I'd --
I had a one-year contract.
Billy Crystal
and Christopher Guest
and Harry Shearer and I
and Rich Hall
had one-year contracts.
And I think at that time,
Dick Ebersol -- It wasn't Lorne.
Lorne had taken his five-year
sabbatical from the show.
They were just trying
to keep it alive.
And Eddie Murphy had left.
And so, anyway,
we got one-year contracts.
And I think it was so stressful
for me every week,
because I treated it like
final exams every week.
I think if I'd known I was going
to be there for five years,
I would have taken it easy.
But every --
You know, and I was
a writer, too, so.
And Billy Crystal always tells
one of his favorite moments is
it's 2:00 in the morning,
and the read-through
is the next day.
And in those days, you had to
slide the script under the door,
'cause they had to be typed.
-Yeah.
-So you had to slide it
by 7:00 a.m., I think,
on Wednesday morning.
And so, it's Wednesday morning,
I'm sorry,
about 4:00 in the morning,
and he's leaving, and he knocks
on my office door,
and he says, "How is it going?"
I said, "Oh, good."
And he looks over my shoulder,
and it says,
"Ed Grimley's apartment,
open on."
Nothing else written.
[ Both laugh ]
Complete and utter panic
and despair.
Then you have
a great show Saturday,
and then 48 hours later,
you feel like a failure,
'cause you have no new ideas
for Ringo, the host, or whoever.
-Yeah, it was not a -- Success
was not a domino at "SNL."
Like, it very much fell
and did not connect in any way,
shape, or form to the next show.
Like, you could be as hot
as possible on one Saturday
and then just ice cold.
-But do you think I'm --
Do you think -- Or is it just
what everyone feels?
In other words, that sense of,
"Had I known
I was going to stay longer,
I would have chilled more," or
would I have been just as tense?
-I think you'd be just as tense
because even though
the contracts people sign now
are longer,
it doesn't mean that you can't
get fired after a year.
And I think most people
after a few episodes
start thinking that way.
-No one fires the Marty Short.
No one fires the Marty Short.
-[ Laughs ]
-I know what you mean.
I know what you mean.
-Yes.
-But I'm talking about my world
and my life.